[Musik]
heute in wales bereits eingeblendet wir
reagieren heute zusammen auf die zweite
folge von klassenfahrt sie geht fremd oh
mein gott ich habe überhaupt keine
erwartungen
rainer schild ehre was schauen wir auf
der canon ist heute sein handy fallen
ach das ist jetzt was in der letzten
folge geschah das kann ich euch aber
auch kurz erklären und zwar ist eine
berliner schulklasse gerade auf
klassenfahrt irgendwo auf den kompletten
dorf und innerhalb der klasse gibt es
voll komische leute und auch streit und
eifersucht und so weiter und so fort
das hauptthema der letzten folge war
allerdings dass die julien das ist die
die damit den zwei unterschiedlichen
augen die joline ist mit dem tennis
zusammen und die julien liebt dänen
kenneth aber nicht so doll wieder
kennedy julien liebt und deswegen will
die julie fremdgehen heute abend mit
einem jungen namens stanley
das ist der hier also es jetzt spannend
[Musik]
jetzt wieder sein handy fallen
[Applaus]
kubrat klassen frau mein gott ich machen
der ultimative test und nein der letzten
wir sind ein paar sekunden in der neuen
heutigen zweiten folge kratz
klassenfahrt und was macht er lässt
direkt wieder sein handy hier fallen
nein das gibt es doch nicht ganz das ist
ganz klar gesagt es ist so bescheuert
aber auf der anderen seite auch echt
große respekt an rheine spielt das so am
durchwinken lassen
keine gute idee
helikopter crash test gemacht und ist
das ganze gemeinde ohne scheiß hast du
zu lieben sich sie ganz zu verlieren
jolie die wahrscheinlich gerade schon am
fremdgehen ist ja viel und ich habe
statistiken gelesen ganz viele und der
häufigste der größte grund für trennung
sind affäre
aha
hahahaha solltet ihr ihn wirklich mit
irgend jemand anderem schreiben das wäre
schon ganz schön wie es ja ich mache
richtig aggressiv dass du die ganze zeit
mit jungs schreibt irgend etwas
verheimlicht im jahr
ja gut erkannt mit deinen drei
gehirnzellen kenneth fragen wie ich
vielleicht doch hier übernachten könnte
weil
die viel wasser
lehrerin übernachten also wer mag sie
ihm verübeln du kannst nicht bei mir
übernachten von der schule fliegen ich
wollte sie auch nur kurz war dass die
anderen schüler heute abend machen
wollen habe solche leute einfach rum
hetzen dann bei der lehrerin
was haben die denn davon verstehe nicht
was es geht um eine kleine schlecht
ich habe viel schlaf das stück wiederum
balearen einfach auf einer klassenfahrt
sagen hey wenn diese aufgaben machen es
doch gut dass die ein bisschen was
trinken und hey mein lieber georg ich
hoffe du findest einen schlafplatz
kaisers
ich habe den jungs ein bisschen handy
und macht so ich war gerade draußen mit
den jungs ein bisschen der handy rum
geholfen und so rund
ich kann schon verstehen dass sie gar
keinen bock mehr drauf hast du da das
geht dich nichts an
ich habe den jungs gesprochen und die
meinen das ist okay wenn man in der
beziehung mal nachhaken wieso schreibt
ich schaue mir auch und kein mädchen
beziehung unsere beziehung läuft schon
lange nicht mehr
ich bin super enttäuscht von julien
wir hatten letztes jahr unser
dreimonatige ist und ich habe eine
collage mit lautern bildern
zusammengestellt
keine ahnung einfach dass ihre mandl zu
ändern alter der heute richtig klasse
doch lieber ein bisschen handys fallen
wir sind seit drei monaten in einer
beziehung und jetzt reicht es langsam
mal wollen wir heiraten und kinder
machen wir wollen doch alle nur unseren
spaß ist so die sind auch drei monate
für die beziehung reicht doch vollkommen
aus dessen was mich auf der klassenfahrt
richtig klar geworden dass die ganzen
jungs alle viel zu oberflächlich für
mich sind
chayenne sagt dass die ganzen jungs viel
zu oberflächlich sind
ich kann mich noch daran erinnern der
erste satz von cayenne war könnte genau
jetzt im hilton seien in moskau bei
meinen eltern wo bin ich
drexler aber ja ja ja denn alle jungs
sind zu oberflächlich ich glaub ich
bräuchte ein freund der wirklich
tiefgründig ist emotional ist mir sein
wahres ich zeigen dass ich da bin ich ja
fünf falls ja wie er ab nach moskau der
guard und deswegen bin ich so froh dass
ich hoffe markieren die allein auch
schon reden ist dass irgendwelche
kulturen svenja also es ist nicht
einfach in die hose ausziehen braucht
wirklich von tiefgründigen jungen
coole story obwohl ich brauche gar nicht
sagen
[Gelächter]
ja daher sollte man mir auf jeden fall
nicht folgen mädels was haltet ihr davon
mal ganz kurz wenn sie bitte ihre
leggins das nächste mal noch höher
tragen was haltet ihr davon heute
richtig zu saufen kommt schon seid dabei
und nein eine brille becken tut mir echt
leid ich erinnere mich noch als er sich
warum alle pflanzen unserem schulgarten
kümmern muss dass der level team einem
streich behrendt hat dann alle pflanzen
mit dem spray angesprüht und dann
angezündet
ich verstehe nicht warum die leute so
gemein zu gerds sind alle begonnen auf
die ideale pflanzen mit deo einzusprühen
dann kriegen sie mal die hanse
sind sie dabei dem south wales oder gibt
mir ordentlich ab
madame strecken sind sogar georg ist da
also das jetzt übrigens der typ der mit
der julien dann irgendwie immer noch was
flüstert ihr dann war wichtig gerade war
wichtig aber wir ertrinken später ein
jahr beträgt noch ihr haus ich komme
wieder
du weißt schon jetzt machen erstmal wort
ergreifen und des teams sind raus zu
sehen musste nicht heißt dass die beiden
noch zusammen sind wir haben wir in der
schule projektwoche
vielleicht kann ja doch ein team
zusammen das projekt für biologie er bei
dem aber vielleicht sollte ich auch raus
sind zusammen das projekt machen es doch
haben wir dann habt ihr in drei jahren
projekt also für die schule dann also
ich sollte eigentlich nicht sagen aber
vielleicht bist du wirklich mal besser
nachschauen was die machen projekt woran
ich doch gesagt ja gheneff projektwoche
brothers voll alter
was macht er jetzt kommt sogar seine
sondereffekt rein
auch sein handy
diese corp ist echt der wahnsinn
[Musik]
das war's
die folge ist an der stelle vorbei also
das war so zickert der beschissen
cliffhanger beziehungsweise der beste
cliffhanger in der stelle dann den ich
hier gesehen habe also ich bin auf jeden
fall gespannt wie es weiter geht wie
bereits gesagt wenn ich mir die dritte
folge nächstes wochenende zusammen mit
euch anschauen soll dann schreibt und
die kommentare last einen daumen hoch
bei diesem video da und jetzt kommt das
auto
[Musik]